after attending law school and interning
at a law firm
she realized her real passion was in
design and she took the leap and well
it paid off so since she's collaborated
with air jordan
and was just named the first woman's
creative director at
foot locker and has her own street wear
brand that sells jewelry
apparel accessories which have been worn
by like sizza alicia keys
lauryn hill i've bought a lot of stuff
at her store
actually some of my favorite earrings in
the world please welcome melody asani
hi melody how are you i'm doing
so well how are you i love
your brand so much
thank you that's so sweet you know i was
just trying to think about when the
first time
like my first memory of you and i
remember
i was in the sixth grade and the first
time i'd ever heard
the term it girl was associated with you
oh and i remember thinking like yeah
that's an it girl and i knew what it was
instantly
because of you oh my gosh melanie that's
so i cause you are such um
you have so much street cred you
started also doing a style that is now
the biggest trend here to stay which is
street
streetwear
you were so ahead of the curve so to
hear that from you i'm blown away
because
i've always admired you and i wanted to
ask you took a big risk
you were a lawyer you had a dream you
felt in your gut a magnetic pull to do
something else
what do you say to people who feel that
way and are too afraid to leave the
stability of their job and chase a dream
it's really hard but it's really the
most important thing you can do
i feel like it really comes down to the
fact of like you have to
ask yourself who you're living your life
for and
i really feel like it's our job to
figure out who we are and why we're here
and
you know where each little design so we
need to unfold
our design instead of just repeat the
past whoa
i'm blown away by that statement it's
going to haunt me in the best way all
day
it makes so much sense and sometimes you
can't talk about a dream until you
really acknowledge reality because then
it's just
all too lofty and you found that dream
you realized it you executed it and it's
a huge success and i was wondering
if you would give some wisdom to a young
small business owner in a segment are
you ready melody we're calling
minute master class
okay today we have schaefer and she's a
senior
in high school who at the age of 16
started her own clothing company called
hey friends i love it take a look
hi my name is schaefer santos and i'm
the owner and creator of hey friends
here at hey friends we sell a bunch of
graphic tees in the occasional jean
jacket
with a bunch of sayings and affirmations
if you're wondering this one is my
favorite
i started my clothing line almost two
years ago now because i have a huge love
for fashion and business
i also grew up in a family business uh
so this is very inspiring me and i have
a huge love for what i do
and i i feel very lucky that i found my
passion so young right now the biggest
problem that i'm having is
like the time aspect i'm still a
full-time student i'm actually a senior
in high school this year
and i have two jobs on top of hey
friends so the day i can make hey
friends my full-time career and just job
is
my end goal for me and it's crazy and
thank you so so much
and here she is now hi shafer
how are you i'm so good i love your
company by the way
i was trolling your instagram and i just
really really love your product and i
think it's really beautiful
and uplifting and i'm an optimist so
i really gravitated towards it i want to
throw this all to melody because she's
the one who has
truly done this so melody you'll have 60
seconds on the clock to tell
her everything you know about being
successful in business are you ready for
your minute master class
i'm ready all right shafer what's your
question
how are you able to make that switch
from a regional to a national audience
go well i think to we have social media
right now
which is the blessing you have so just
putting as much content out
out there as possible and word of mouth
women know how to spread word about
something they love
around the world faster than the
internet so tell all your friends
and trust that they'll tell theirs and
as long as you keep your focus
and dedicate what time you do have to it
slowly over time you'll be able to
invest more and more energy into your
passion and less into
the things that you have to do to
support your passion
exactly and slow and steady wins the
race
and keep going keep your eye on the
prize shaffer i think what you've got is
true to your heart and you're passionate
about it
that's one of the biggest things is the
passion that's what's going to make you
stay up at night
work weekends and do everything it takes
to get it done if that passion is not
there you won't do that and if you don't
do that you won't get the gig that's the
way it works
um okay melody i can't thank you enough
for being with us today i have been an
uber fan for as long as i can remember
it is such an honor to like do this with
you and schaefer
keep going i'm gonna be on your
instagram we're gonna put you on our
website as well
to honor that melody mentality of word
of mouth
and social media that prescription was
so brilliant melody i totally agree so
let's help you foster that
thank you so much you guys by the way
minute master class
so awesome i love it thank you so much
you guys